>>> NEW TONIGHT.
THE JANUARY 6th SELECT COMMITTEE
REQUESTING A SECOND SITTING
MEMBER OF CONGRESS TO COME SPEAK
TO INVESTIGATORS.
THIS TIME, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN -- ONE OF
FORMER-PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
STAUNCHEST ALLIES.
SOMEONE WHO HAS ADMITTED TO
TALKING TO TRUMP MULTIPLE TIMES
ON JANUARY 6th.
AND JUST LAST WEEK, THE
COMMITTEE REVEALED THAT TEXT
MESSAGES IT OBTAINED FROM THE
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS INCLUDED TEXTS FROM
JORDAN DETAILING A WAY TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION JUST A DAY
BEFORE THE INSURRECTION.
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY -- THE
OTHER REPUBLICAN LAWMAKER ASKED
TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE -- HE REJECTED THAT
REQUEST JUST YESTERDAY.
JESSICA SCHN
JES
JESSICA SCHNEIDER IS OUT FRONT
FOR US NOW.
JESSICA, WHAT MORE ARE YOU
LEARNING?
>> THE COMMITTEE IS ACTUALLY
TELLING CONGRESSMAN JORDAN IN
THIS LETTER THEY KNOW HE SPOKE
WITH TRUMP AT LEAST ONCE, IF NOT
MULTIPLE TIMES THEY SAY ON
JANUARY 6th.
SO NOW, THEY WANT HIM TO SIT FOR
A VOLUNTARY INTERVIEW AS SOON AS
JANUARY 3rd.
BUT FROM WHAT WE HAVE SEEN HERE,
IT IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN WILL
COOPERATE.
HE IS ALREADY, IN THE PAST,
WARNED THAT THE COMMITTEE
TARGETING GOP LAWMAKERS IN ANY
CAPACITY -- HE SAID IT WOULD BE
MET WITH POLITICAL RETRIBUTION
IF REPUBLICANS RETAKE THE HOUSE
AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, YOU
REFERENCED IT.
WE SAW CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY.
HE LASHED OUT AT THE COMMITTEE'S
LEGITIMACY, ALREADY, THIS WEEK.
AND HE REBUFFED THEIR REQUEST TO
INTERVIEW HIM.
SO, SO FAR TONIGHT, NO RESPONSE
FROM JORDAN.
BUT THE COMMITTEE IS REALLY
TRYING TO THROW HIS WORDS BACK
AT HIM BY WRITING HIM IN THIS
LETTER THAT JORDAN SAID BACK IN
AUGUST THAT HE HAD, QUOTE,
NOTHING TO HIDE.
BUT THERE IS AT LEAST THAT ONE
TEXT MESSAGE OF NOTE.
JORDAN FORWARDED A TEXT TO
FORMER-CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS ON JANUARY 5th OUTLINING
THIS PLAN FOR VP MIKE PENCE AND
HERE IS EXACTLY WHAT IT SAID,
KATE.
ON JANUARY 6th, 2021, VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE, AS
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE, SHOULD
CALL OUT ALL ELECTORAL VOTES
THAT HE BELIEVES ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS NO ELECTORAL
VOTES AT ALL.
OF COURSE, THAT WAS ALL PART OF
A PLOT TO GET PENCE TO BLOCK
CERTIFICATION, WHICH HE
ULTIMATELY REFUSED TO DO, KATE.
BUT JORDAN'S SPOKESPERSON HAS
TOLD US ABOUT THAT TEXT.
THEY SAY IT WAS ACTUALLY WRITTEN
BY A FORMER DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THAT
JORDAN WAS JUST FORWARDING THE
TEXT ON TO MEADOWS.
BUT OF COURSE, IT IS CLEAR THE
ADMITEE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THAT
TEXT AND THEY WANT TO FIND OUT
THROUGH JORDAN WHAT TRUMP WAS UP
TO INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE ON
JANUARY 6th.
IT'S INTERESTING, KATE, BECAUSE
THE COMMITTEE IN THIS LETTER --
THEY SAY THEY KNOW THAT TRUMP
WAS WATCHING TV COVERAGE OF THE
CAPITOL ATTACK FROM HIS PRIVATE
DINING ROOM NEXT TO THE OVAL
OFFICE THAT DAY.
AND THEY SAY EVEN AFTER THE
CROWD DISPERSED, THAT TRUMP WAS
STILL TRYING TO DELAY OR IMPEDE
THE VOTE COUNT.
SO, THERE IS A LOT THIS
COMMITTEE WANTS TO KNOW.
THEY ARE HOPING THEY CAN DO IT
THROUGH CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
KATE.
UNLIKELY HE WILL SIT DOWN AND WE
WILL SEE IF ANY SFEENS FOLLOW.
KATE.
>> JESSICA, THANKS FOR LAYING IT
OUT FOR US.
FOR MORE, LET ME BRING IN JOHN
DEAN.
WATERGATE WHISTLE-BLOWER AND
FORMER NIXON WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU, JOHN.
SO, JIM JORDAN, WHO WAS -- WHO
WAS -- WHO KEVIN McCARTHY HAD
ACTUALLY PICKED TO PUT ON THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE TO REPRESENT
REPUBLICANS AT THE BEGINNING,
NOW HE IS BECOMING A CENTRAL
FIGURE IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
HOW IMPORTANT DO YOU THINK HIS
TESTIMONY COULD BE TO WHAT -- TO
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK IT'S
VITAL TESTIMONY AS THE LETTER
SHOWS, THEY HAVE PRETTY GOOD
IDEA WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY'D LIKE TO HEAR IT FROM HIM.
I'M SURE THERE'S MUCH MORE --
MUCH, MUCH MORE HE COULD ADD TO
WHAT THEY KNOW.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW IT'S JIM
JORDAN.
JIM JORDAN IS A TRUMP ACOLYTE.
HE IS NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
TO UPSET HIS MASTER.
IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE.
SO, THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TROUBLE.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO USE THE SUBPOENA AND IT --
IT'S GOING TO BE TESTED.
>> ONE KEY QUESTION WITH JORDAN,
REALLY EVER SINCE JANUARY 6th,
HAS BEEN WHAT WERE HIS
COMMUNICATIONS WITH DONALD TRUMP
ON JANUARY 6th?
BECAUSE THE QUESTION HAS BECOME
ALL THE MORE INTERESTING AS
JORDAN, HIMSELF, HAS TRIPPED
OVER ANSWERING IT MULTIPLE
TIMES.
LET ME PLAY THIS FOR YOU.
>> I HAVE TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT SO MANY -- I CAN'T
REMEMBER ALL THE DAYS I HAVE
TALKED TO HIM BUT I CERTAINLY
TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT.
I SPOKE WITH HIM THAT DAY AFTER?
I THINK AFTER?
I DON'T KNOW IF I SPOKE WITH HIM
IN THE MORNING OR NOT.
I IOR -- I JUST DON'T KNOW.
>> OF COURSE I TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT.
I TALKED TO HIM THAT DAY.
I HAVE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T RECALL THE NUMBER OF
TIMES.
>> JOHN, WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THAT?
>> WELL, THAT'S NOT THE NORMAL
JORDAN ANSWER.
HE IS PRETTY CRISP AND PRETTY
CLEAR ON MOST OF HIS ANSWERS.
HIS MIND IS PROBABLY TRYING TO
CALCULATE, WELL, WHAT KIND OF
EXPOSURE DO I HAVE AT THIS STAGE
IN ANSWERING THAT QUESTION?
AND I THINK HE DOES HAVE
EXPOSURE BECAUSE OF THE TEXTS HE
FORWARDED THE DAY BEFORE, I'LL
TELL YA, IF THEY EVER START
PURSUING CONSPIRACY CHARGES, HE
WALKED RIGHT INTO A CONSPIRACY,
UH, TO OBSTRUCT CONGRESS.
TO -- WAS IT A SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY?
MAY -- MAY WELL HAVE BEEN.
SO I THINK HE KNOWS HE HAS
EXPOSURE, AND IF HE EVER IS IN
FRONT OF THAT COMMITTEE, HE WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO TAKE THE FIFTH.
THAT'S PROBABLY ANOTHER REASON
HE DOESN'T WANT TO GO.
>> YEAH, YOU -- YOU CAN ASSUME
THAT.
LOOK, REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
SCOTT PERRY.
HE REJECTED THIS VOLUNTARY
REQUEST AS WELL, OUTRIGHT.
KIND OF SLAMMING THE COMMITTEE.
OBVIOUSLY, JORDAN IS LIKELY TO
FOLLOW SUIT IN THAT.
YOU'VE SAID THAT THEY SHOULD
COMPEL HIM WITH A SUBPOENA.
BUT HOW BIG OF A DEAL WOULD THIS
BE?
BECAUSE IS THERE A RISK AT THIS
POINT, AS WE HAVE KIND OF SEEN
THIS TREND OF JUST PERSON AFTER
PERSON, ALLY AFTER ALLY, DEFYING
SUBPOENAS THAT IT JUST
DOESN'T -- IT DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING OF THE IMPACT THEY WANT
IT TO AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, IF THE IMPACT THEY WANT
TO GET IS THE FACT THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
TRUMP WON'T COOPERATE, I THINK
THEY ARE DOING A GOOD JOB OF
SHOWING THAT.
AND THEY'RE STACKING THEM UP,
ONE AFTER ANOTHER.
THE -- IF IT EVER COMES TO A
SHOWDOWN AND JORDAN WOULD
PROBABLY TAKE THIS TO COURT AS
OTHERS HAVE.
THE -- THE -- IT'S A DIFFERENT
PRIVILEGE THIS TIME THAT'S IN
PLAY.
IT'S CALLED THE SPEECH AND
DEBATE CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WITH A SAFE HAVEN FOR
ANYTHING THEY DO IS PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
NOW, I DON'T THINK PLANNING OR
ASSISTING OR ASKING TO CALL OFF
AN INSURRECTION IS ANY WAY
CONNECTED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T KNOW THE
OUTER REACH OF THIS PRIVILEGE.
IT'S ONE THAT'S BEEN MAYBE A
DOZEN CASES ON IT SO THAT'S WHAT
HE WOULD RELY ON IF HE -- IF
PUSH COMES TO SHOVE.
AND I DON'T THINK PEOPLE REALLY
WANT TO TEST THAT PRIVILEGE TOO
MUCH.
>> DEFINITELY SEEN A LOT OF
PEOPLE REALLY TESTING THE OU